okay let's berserk
and
what to play i'll play e4
try and be aggressive
oh it's a french
trying to think of tricky things to play
against the french
i'll play a two nights attack
yeah i can't i can't play stafford or
naglinson against the french
i think i've ever seen this move so
early
i'll play queen g4 we'll be aggressive
we'll try and uh question black's
meaning in life i'll take with the
d-pawn
that's kind of stafford-like this pawn
is attacked
playing knight f3 and thanks for subbing
main lion appreciate that queen g3
so there's this this idea also this idea
it's hard for black to deal with both
things
[Music]
yeah let's go for this and then bishop
d3
so this is only safe square for the
queen
and e5 is now a threat
oh it's playable
i want to go insane take take
probably doesn't work
play this move
there's some weird ideas of sacking a
bishop sagging queen and then mating
oh thank you we 22y appreciate that
oh and strike khali had their first oh
no my queen stafford
checkmate today that's great to hear
keep it up
but yeah in all seriousness uh nerdetsky
made like a
a very extensive video of how to how to
basically refute the stafford
it was kind of sad but
it was going to happen eventually
what to do here
i want to do crazy things here
even though they probably don't work
they almost work and it's really close
to working
i'm taking time here because there's a
really cool idea
but i don't see i don't see the proper
execution
unfortunately
like i'm thinking bishop c4 takes and
then takes
i have to do it though it looks so cool
or i could check oh
my bishop ah the bishop's hanging
the bishop is not defended by anything
at least the pawn the pawn won't be
taken for free
so it'll it'll die a hero
i'll take a pawn oh no my queen
my queen my beautiful queen
forgot that pawns can take diagonally
pawns are so confusing and just.com
released a variant where pawns can
capture sideways i think
or move sideways making them even more
confusing
opponents perplexed oh opponent doesn't
take my queen
oh no my rook i keep losing all my
pieces
here's all my pieces
it's so sad but they'll be remembered
they'll be remembered so i'm down the
bishop i'm about to be down a rook
and then life will go on
opponents so confused that they're
probably just gonna flag
like these moves are what's the term
when
someone's frozen in shock
petrifying or shocking
opponent can't handle all my all the
free stuff i'm giving them
oh opponent fork me too
i hope my opponent's not reading chat
wow 97
what is 97
that's such a random move
it's a really random move da
my brook and my queen they're still
hanging
okay i lost a rook
so i'm down a bishop in a rook
i'm probably just losing here
hmm i'm actually like kind of just
losing
ah my queen ah i can't stop losing
all my pieces
at least i'm up on time that's nice
oh opponent doesn't take it
i can move back
confusing situation let's move back
so back is lost casting rights
ah my pawn both pawns are hanging
i can't play anything without losing
something
is everything defended oh my pawn still
hanging
oh i have so leachat tells me i have
three pawns
for rook and knight
that was a good move
and when in doubt push upon
defending both things
ah my pawn oh thanks scraw
something at tier one appreciate that
for two months
i mean the the benefit here is that
black's underdeveloped
kind of
let's retreat going for e5
i have to try and win back some material
yeah e5 time
so knight's pinned and attacked oh
black is hiding the king can take
and retreat always retreats
oh thanks for the bits
[Music]
yamborghini
how much material am i down
play this move hey it's a little pocket
welcome back a little pocket with
large letters how's it going
oh this is supposed to be a time
scramble
okay uh let's move quicker
let's move quicker play this fancy move
i could have taken a free bishop ah
i could still take a free bishop
or i could blunder a night da my night
like 15 seconds uh-oh let's not lose
this
no i like watching more than
playing that's how bad i see oh that's
okay no one's perfect
oh okay
opponent had me yeah that's why i said
no
this was like a real oh no
it was a pin it was also a blunder
that was a messy game yeah don't try
that stuff at home
i don't think these moves were good this
move was cool though
had to sub for that game oh thanks neil
tennis
i don't know if i want to have more
games like that i feel dirty